Speaker 1: So we continue to try to sort out,
what, twenty twenty two and twenty twenty four are
going to look like politically, what's the country
going to look like culturally? What's going to
be the situation with the pandemic? What will be
the situation with climate change? And one of the
questions that remains is, is Donald Trump going
to be a candidate in twenty twenty four? Because
as of this point in time, the nomination
seems his for the taking he's got. He owns
the Republican Party. Lindsey Graham said it
and Genk Ugur said, I mean, there's really no
the guy owns the Republican Party. They can't
the voters can't seem to get away from the guy
during an interview two weeks ago or one one and a
half or maybe it was like three years ago. No, it
was in the last couple of weeks. Trump told Maria
Bartiromo that he, for campaign finance reasons,
can't make any announcements right now. But he's
decided and he thinks people will be really happy
and that he's going to do very well. The first
signal that maybe he would be running at the
same time, when I was on Michael Cohen's program
the other day, Michael Cohen said, I don't think
Trump is going to run. There is a new report,
very interesting report from Rolling Stone,
which says Trump is telling his dinner
plans he's planning to run for president.
It was originally reported, as Trump is
telling his friends. And then, of course,
it's like it's not really clear Donald Trump
has friends or normal relationships anyway.
But the report from Rolling Stone's Andy Kroll is
that in conversations with at least three people
top, a top Republican source says Trump has
said he wants another run at the White House.
Brace yourself. Donald Trump plans plans to run
again. At least that's what the former president
is telling dinner buddies. Trump has told at
least three people he's dined with in recent
months that he plans to run in 2004. A former
senior official at the RNC tells Rolling Stone,
quote, I have three friends who have had
dinner with him in the last couple of months.
All three reported that his current plans are
to run for president in twenty twenty four. The
former RNC official says now whether he does or
not is a different issue. We've still got three
years to go, but he's telling people that. The
RNC official says the first two dinners took place
in late spring, but the third dinner happened in
the last two weeks. The first two companions came
away from their conversation, convinced Trump was
serious and running. The third said he left the
dinner. Not one hundred percent sure Trump wants
to run, but he likes being in the conversation.
He wants to freeze the field and he wants
his name out there. A spokeswoman for Trump
did not respond to requests for comment about
Trump's recent dinner conversations and whether
he plans to run for president again. I think
it's a completely legitimate thing to mention
that just because Trump says he's going to run
and just because Trump might really intend to run,
he may not run. And I continue to say it's his
health that may be a factor in that there it could
be a serious losses in twenty twenty two. It could
be that he's talked out of it in some way. I could
at the same time believe that Trump believes he's
running and yet he won't run in the end. Couple
more things from the article. A former Trump
adviser who speaks with Trump, members of Trump's
inner circle says he's been briefed on similar
conversations that reflect the former president's
current thinking. The adviser says Trump started
to give indications in private back in May
that he was leaning towards running again and
that the more recent signs suggest he wants to
run. The adviser says, all the people I talk
to who deal with him directly think as of now,
he is running. Now what is? Why do we care about
this, guys? Can't we move on the fact that this
guy, no one is like a baby dictator and his
supporters are still with him. Number two,
he lost everything for Republicans. He lost
them. The House in twenty eighteen, he lost them.
The Senate in twenty twenty. He lost them, the
White House in twenty twenty. He plays coy with
the vaccine but gets it in secret, but then tells
him in March and they don't get it. And it's not
clear who's responsible for their deaths.
And it's not clear they even know or care.
And he still has the vast majority of the
Republican electorate behind him. And at least
from a public standpoint, the majority of the
Republican officials behind him. Not only does it
tell us how broken, depraved and disgusting this
Republican Party is and this electorate, as it
tells us a lot about the fact that this guy could
still be a major player, if not the presumptive
nominee, if he chooses to run and if he's healthy
enough to run in twenty, twenty four. It's quite
stunning. And you know what? What was the mistake?
Many of us, myself included, made in twenty in
twenty sixteen. I overestimated the intelligence
of the Republican primary electorate, number one.
And number two, I overestimated the degree to
which the non wacky right wingers would uniformly
realize the danger of Trump. Because remember
overwhelmingly why when we say who's to blame for
Trump winning in 2016? Well, the guy chose to run,
sure. But we've got to blame the people who vote
for who voted for him. Primarily, but remember
those people who say they're on the left who
in twenty sixteen were saying, you know, Hillary
and Trump, there are two sides of the same coin.
What that is also partially to blame, so
the mistake I made in twenty sixteen was
I overestimated the intelligence of the Republican
electorate never to make this guy their nominee.
And I overestimated the urgency of the entire
electorate in total so that we would have enough
independents and left wingers and Democrats
and progressives and whoever else to say, no,
there's nothing similar about these two other
than they're both members of Homo sapiens.
We've got to get out there and vote for Hillary
Clinton. And that's why it's so dangerous now.
And that's why the fact that he still owns
this party is so scary and why the fact that
at least based on these reports he plans to
run is something that should horrify us all